so I thought I'd talk about two symbols
that go together alpha and Delta and
both these symbols are used for lots of
different things but when you see them
together at least as an astronomer it
usually means you're measuring the
coordinates or something measuring where
something is on the sky and of course
that's rather important to astronomers
because if you want to point your
telescope at a particular object you
need to know what direction to point it
in and so these are the coordinates we
use for measuring the positions of
things on the sky you give me two
numbers which sort of measure two angles
to tell you where to look in the sky
what direction to point your telescope
in and it's just exactly the same as
giving somebody if you want to tell
somebody where something is on the earth
you give them a longer to deny latitude
so it's measuring position and that's
kind of a position on the sphere we're
doing the same thing but where so the
sphere we're looking at out out at on
the inside or if you like and in fact
they really they're directly analogous
to longitude and latitude in that the
Delta the declination is really just the
latitude it's the latitude at which the
object you're looking at would appear
directly overhead so for example the
pole star which is directly over the
North Pole pretty much if you were
sitting at the North Pole move it
directly above your head is a
declination of plus ninety degrees so
that's the same it's also the latitude
of plus ninety degrees so declination
and latitude directly relate to one
another the second coordinate and a
longitude is a bit more complicated and
the reason why it's a bit more
complicated is of course the u.s.
rotates so what's directly overhead in
terms of longitude at one point it's a
time position east or west you come back
a little while later of course the
Earth's turned and so it's no longer
overhead so the east-west one although
we use the same idea of measuring an
angle around the sky just as you measure
an angle around the earth
you need a zero point so just as the
zero the zero point of longitude is set
by the Greenwich meridian so you need a
zero point for the right ascension scale
and so what we do is we say okay so you
set that zero point to be where the Sun
is in the sky on the 21st of March so on
the the March equinox and so that sort
of sets then sets the zero point and at
that point absolutely everything is
specified and the nice thing is of
course that if you think about what the
earth going around the Sun the earth is
tilted on its axis the equinox is the
point where the earth is neither
pointing towards the Sun or away from
the Sun it's kind of tilted 90 degrees
to the Sun and so every year that occurs
at the same time so though you come
to the same point so the same stars are
behind it so you've really set set a
coordinate system which is reproducible
from year to year but there is a
complication and the complication is
that although the earth kind of comes
back to the same point every year
there's something else that goes on with
the Earth's axis which is that the
Earth's axis actually processes around
the earth behaves like a spinning top
and you know when a spinning top
starting to tire it sort of wobbles
around as it's rotating the earth does
exactly the same thing on a very long
time scale the interaction of the earth
with the gravitational pull of the moon
and the Sun makes its axis wubble around
on a time scale of about 27 thousand
years so over a timescale of twenty
seven thousand years the north
rotational Pole of the earth wobbles
around goes around in a circle describes
a circle and that means that for example
the star that's directly above the pole
changes because the pole points in
different directions so what's currently
the pole star in ten thousand years time
isn't gonna be the pole star anymore so
that's part of the problem but the other
part of the problem is that that means
because the earth is sort of wobbling
around that means that the point on its
orbit where it reaches this magical
point where the axis is neither pointing
towards the Sun or away from the Sun
happens at a different point around the
orbit at different parts of this twenty
seven thousand year cycle and that means
that the stars that are behind the Sun
on the 21st of March actually change so
that the constellation that the Sun
appears to be located in changes on that
twenty seven thousand year timescale so
and so for example this point where the
the where the Sun II is on the 21st of
March when the earth is neither pointed
towards it nor way from it he's called
the first point of Aries it's the point
that sets the zero point of this this
sort of scale for right ascension but
actually it isn't in the constellation
of Aries anymore it's moved around to
Pisces to the next constellation oh so
that where the Sun actually is in the
sky where the Sun appears to be in the
sky on the 21st of March changes over
time over this very long time scale
twenty-seven thousand years but because
these constellations were set up and the
zero point was set up by Ptolemy several
thousand years ago we've already moved
one constellation around over 27,000
years mean things move very large
distances on the sky the whole
coordinate system changes but even from
year to year things change and so if you
don't process your coordinates right you
end up not pointing your telescope in
the right direct and remember telescopes
look at a tiny bit of the sky so even a
small error in where you're pointing
your telescope
means you'll miss the object you were
looking at so one of my colleagues who
should probably remain nameless actually
forgot to process the coordinates right
on a Hubble Space Telescope observation
and ended up not looking at the object
he was interested in looking at at all
but it a completely random blank piece
of sky so yes if you get this wrong it
really has a big impact on day to day
astronomy I am from time to time
confused with an astrologer I should say
I am NOT an astrologer and so any
pronouncements I make on astrology
should be taken in that in that context
however you should bear in mind that
astrologers don't process their
coordinates so for example my son sign
my birth sign is Virgo which in the sort
of naive picture of astrology means that
all the time I was born the Sun was in
the constellation of Virgo now because
of this precession effect the Sun wasn't
actually in the constellation of Virgo
when I was born it was actually in the
constellation of Leo and so the
constellations all kind of mover Shump
their way around over time now the
astrologers claim this doesn't matter
because the astrologers claim that
really what they're measuring is the
time of year that you're born it and of
course that's all taken care off because
the 21st of March this equinox always
happens in spring in the northern
hemisphere autumn in the southern
hemisphere our calendar takes care of
that
it's just the way that the
constellations appear on that particular
day changes and the so the the what are
called tropical astrology is people who
actually track the motion of the Sun in
this way say that it doesn't matter and
really you're just measuring when you
were born according to the time of year
I have a couple of problems with that
firstly it means that really if you're
just using the the names of the
constellations like vo for example
there's just a marker of a particular
time of year it has nothing at all to do
with the conservation now the reason why
that particular birth sign is called Leo
is because the constellation Leo looks a
bit like a lion and so what you're
saying is that association with a lion
is completely it's not relevant to
astrology but then if you actually go
and look in the newspaper and read your
your star stars for the month it'll tell
you you know you're Li annoying
characters means that you're very royal
and regal and what-have-you whereas
actually you know what what these proper
astrologers say is that actually you
know it's nothing at all to do with that
particular constellation we just happen
to call that bit of the sky Leo but it's
nothing to do with the constellation Leo
in the sky and therefore any association
with a lie and surely is completely
round
the other issue is that there are
actually several schools of astrology so
if you follow the Vedic school of
astrology which is Indian astrology they
actually do process their coordinates
and so they actually measure the
position of the Sun and the planets
relative to the constellations and they
actually follow this properly and
actually allow for the fact that the
Earth's x-axis is processing and so they
changed the coordinates appropriately
whereas the Western astrologers the
tropical astrologers don't process their
coordinates and so they end up with
completely different symbols for what
your birth sign is for example and what
this means is is that at least half of
astrologers are talking complete
nonsense personally I'll go for a rather
higher percentage it's I mean the funny
thing is this came up in the news fairly
recently it's just one of those things
somebody put a video on YouTube in fact
where they raise this point about
precession of coordinates and the fact
that the constellations have all moved
around and therefore your sign of the
zodiac is wrong and it's just one of
those things that just went viral and
lots of people picked it up and so I got
picked up by the mainstream media and it
became a big story again and it sort of
annoyed everyone because both the
astronomers and the astrologers are
well-acquainted with this argument and
it's been going on forever and you know
there is no real argument to be had
because there's no science in astrology
so there's not much point in a scientist
confronting an astrologer because we
think they're talking nonsense and they
know they're not